this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Claire so today I'm going to
be presenting on my postdoc postdoctoral
Fellowship which is still in progress
the title of today's talk is a novel
socological approach for promoting
area-wide adoption of organic farming
practices that enhance microbially
needed mediated Pest Control
um so today we're going to be talking a
lot about organic farming practices and
so the organic label or Organic
certification regulates practices that
support various factors within farming
systems so some of the factors that I'm
interested in are the social dynamics
that occur within farming systems
the economic aspects of organic farming
and then of course the ecological
aspects and I'm very interested in the
connection between the social aspects of
sustainability within organic farming
systems and then the ecological outcomes
so one of the ecological outcomes that
we're interested in organic farming
systems
um is microbiome conservation and that's
the reason that I came to Claire's lab
and so Claire found that
Organic Farms help to promote microbiome
diversity over our conventional Farms
and then Claire was able to follow this
uh benefit of the microbiome up through
plant defenses so this is a plot with
salicylic acid here showing that Organic
Farms had higher levels of plants grown
with soil from Organic Farms have higher
levels of salicylic acid
and then finally Claire and her
co-authors were able to track that all
the way out through pest reproduction
where Organic Farms the soils from those
Farms suppressed pest populations and so
the idea here is that Organic Farms help
to conserve a certain aspect of the
microbiome that promotes plant defenses
and suppresses pest populations
um so where my kind of Novel Wrinkle In
This research comes through is that
um
generally we look at organic farming as
kind of this one big system or one big
idea but we know it just by looking at
Claire's data and then also data that
I've produced from other research that
there's a lot of variation within
organic farming systems there's
variation across those farms in terms of
their capacity
I'm sorry I just saw something on his
computer a very variation across organic
farms in terms of their capacity to
promote the microbiome and then from my
research also the um pests the levels of
pests
um vary considerably across Organic
Farms so one can look at this and think
about the ecological benefits of organic
farming vary
and one of the reasons that um the
ecological benefits of organic farming
varies within that label organic farmers
can use a spectrum of practices so if
you go out and you walk around on any
organic farm in New York state they're
going to be using different practices
and and they're not just one homogeneous
unit so for example some of my PhD
research looked at plant diversity with
an organic farming systems and how that
impacted while bee communities and so as
plant diversity increases across Organic
Farms we see increases in ecosystem
services like pollinator visitation to
crops and so what we assume is kind of
underlying this variation in pest
populations must be might be something
similar where organic farmers are using
a spectrum of practices and that
ultimately influences pest populations
um so if we're gonna kind of spin off
that idea a little bit further we
propose that this variation in practice
is
um not only mediates for example
pollinator communities but also
microbiomediated ecosystem services so
we're saying that What organic farmers
do and how that varies across their
Farms ultimately might be impacting the
microbiome and microbiome's capacity to
regulate pest populations
so then I'm taking a step from back from
that I wanted to ask myself why do
organic farming practices vary so
um this is kind of like a why question
right so you're like well if organic
farming practices vary and farmers are
doing different things why are they
doing different things
um and then the second question that
comes out of that is once we know about
this variation and why farmers are doing
different things
um can that variation be leveraged to
promote ecosystem Services uh like pest
suppression that we think is beneficial
so one of the reasons that there might
be variation in farming practices or
across Organic Farms might be due to
Farmers beliefs
um so this is uh starting to step into
the social aspect of my research and
I've shown in my research as well as
other researchers that um if a farmer
for example believes that their
practices are in uh are impacting
pollinator populations so they're like
proponents of pollinators like you see
over here
um they intend to engage in pollinator
conservation efforts so this is showing
that what someone thinks about what
they're doing ultimately can drive
changes in their practices
um to promote conservation efforts
um in addition to that we think that
there are a lot of reasons uh farming
practices vary
um and some of those could be related to
their time in organic management uh this
is some data from my PhD work that
showed that over time in organic farming
systems
um that mediates the assembly mechanism
of pollinator communities so you can
kind of think about time and organic
management at a proxy for different
changes and practices that are occurring
over time within those farming systems
um and then you can also look at other
researchers work on this topic and find
that factors
um in terms of like farmer demographics
such as their income can influence
better management practices
um like how they manage the soil
so it's important to say that not only
um is what someone's thinking or their
beliefs mediating what they're doing but
there are also a lot of other external
factors or factors occurring within the
farming systems that can can also also
influence the the farming practices that
they adopt
so taking this um one level larger is
that um what we've talked about so far
is uh sort of like this variation within
organic farming systems
um but what we wanted to do for this
project is uh scale this um process up
so could we take what we saw from
Claire's study uh and scale it up to an
area-wide program to promote the
conservation of the microbiome uh
enhance microbiome media ecosystem
services like pest suppression
um and one of the things that we've um
come to realize with area-wide
management is if it requires
coordination and coordinated adoption
especially when it comes to suppressing
uh pest populations
um so that's something that we're
looking at in this study as well and
that's something that my co-advisor on
this project Dr shadiatala is helping
with
so um this is kind of one of the general
framing questions for the study is uh
can socioecological models study
adoption and ecological outcomes a broad
Geographic scales
and um I want to go ahead and introduce
what socioecological models are and I
think I've already kind of alluded to
this so the idea is that
um what someone believes uh influences
the practices that they use so that's
the first part of the socioecological
model
um and then through someone's beliefs
that influence their practices that then
mediates ecosystem services so this is
the part of
um the research that I've focused on a
lot of my career which is just
evaluating how farming practice is uh
influence an ecosystem service within a
farming system and this is the part of
the model that I've also done before
which is just looking at how police
influence practices
um but for this study I wanted to create
a full socioecological model which would
evaluate
um what someone believes uh and how that
influences their farming practices so
what a farmer believes and how that
influences their farming practices and
then the ecological outcomes all within
a United model
and in addition to that this is called a
static socioecological model but as part
of the project we're looking at how what
we can determine in terms of the
ecological outcomes in their relation to
farming practices how that information
can be extended back to Farmers and
ultimately change their beliefs and
shape the adoption of farming practice
to help support ecosystem services on
farms
foreign so so far I've like used a
pollinator as a model but you can uh
apply this to any ecological outcome and
really any type of farming system that
you might be interested in and so um for
this study what we're looking at is how
farmer beliefs mediate their farming
practices like pesticide use for example
and how those farming practices
ultimately mediate
um ecological outcomes in the microbiome
plant defenses and pest suppression and
then how learning about that knowledge
can be extended back to Farmers to again
mediate and shape the practices that
they're using to promote these types of
ecosystem services
so this is the premise of my USDA
post-doctoral Fellowship again I'm
working with Dr Claire Castile on this
but I'm also working with Dr Shadi atal
at the University of Illinois who is a
social scientist and Economist and does
this type of modeling so we're coming
coming at it where um Claire has been
bringing in uh kind of the technical
tools to evaluate the microbiome uh and
plant defenses and shoddy has been
helping a lot with the the modeling
approaches
so today I'm going to demonstrate this
part of the model first which is how
does someone how does what a farmer
believe
um influence what they what they do so
their farming practices
and then I'm also going to start showing
you some of the ecological results so
I'm going to show you that logical
results for the microbiome and then I'm
also going to show you that logical
results for pest suppression so the idea
here is at the end of the lecture you'll
see in a unified model how what someone
believes can ultimately relate an
ecological outcome result in ecological
outcomes within organic farming
so the first part which is going to
relate uh what Farmers believe to their
farming practices that they adopt is a
paper that we uh that is now in review
at people in nature and the title of
that is motivating organic farmers to
adopt practices that support the pest
depressive microbiome relies on
understanding their beliefs
um
so I'll go ahead and get into the
methods for this paper
so we started with site selection
through What's called the USDA Integrity
database it's a broad database of
organic farmers there's about 16 000
organic farmers in this database and the
value of that of these farming systems
is around 4.2 billion dollars annually
and then as we narrowed our selection to
New York there's about 1500 organic
farms in New York state and it's about a
216 million dollar
um business annually
so um some additional filters on our
site selection we only wanted to work
with vegetable Farmers small fruit and
vegetable Farmers
um so that narrowed our selection down
to about 280 Farms or so and then I sent
this list of farmers out to Coronet
Cooperative Extension and they were able
to tell me if the farmers met my uh
selection criteria
um okay so um as you might know or have
inferred that a lot of the data that I
collect comes through survey instruments
so to evaluate what someone believes or
what they are thinking you have to ask
them through a survey tool
um so I'm going to talk a lot about the
survey tool but I also brought a copy of
the survey tool for all of you to look
at today so um this is just imagine that
you were the farmer
um and that you received this in the
mail and I'll just pass it around and
you're feel free to take a look at it so
you can get an idea of how this um this
all works and maybe you're interested in
writing survey tools yourself
um so I'm going to talk a little bit
about the development of the survey tool
so the survey evaluated uh the farming
practices of the farmer so we were
interested in farming practices like no
tillage use of cover cropping Etc we
also evaluated their demographics such
as their education their income things
like that farm characteristics time and
organic management the area of their
Farm or some of the variables that we
collected and then
um it's really important for you to
understand that when we're talking about
what someone believes
um what I'm talking about is what
Farmers think about the microbiome and
how their farming practices or other
factors might be influencing the
microbiome within their farming system
so um these are kind of the belief
variables here in this importance of
category so we asked farmers do you
think no tillage is influencing the
microbiome within your farming system do
you think climate change uh is
influencing the microbiome within your
farming system these types of questions
and then they they
um they ranked uh how much they believed
in uh those causal factors
um we also evaluated their motivations
to adopt a new practice discovered by
the project to support the microbiometh
in their farms and those motivations
spanned from economic reasons uh the
pest suppression reason interactions
with extension agents or their peers as
well as outcomes for biodiversity
um so the survey also included a soil
sampling kit which is uh which is the
part of the
um part of the project that's going to
allow me to build this what I call the
static socioecological model which
relates what they believe to their
practices reported in the survey Tool uh
and then ultimately the ecological
outcomes that we derived from the soil
and I'm going to be talking a little bit
about this later so in the survey packet
they receive a sampling bag and um
instructions on how to do that
so this survey when underwent extensive
pre-testing from 20 extension agents and
Farmers throughout the state of New York
and it's important to remember that
um that these survey tools they are
essentially perceived by who receives
them and so when you send someone a
survey tool they have to understand what
you're asking them you have to they have
to understand
um that you're asking them about a
specific practice uh for example no
tillage
um
you have to use the language of a farmer
so that they select the correct option
otherwise if they might say oh no I'm
not doing that then you're you're
missing out on critical data that that
you would have been able to collect if
you had asked the right questions in the
right way so I wanted to thank all the
folks who are extremely helpful in
developing the survey Tool uh including
our very own Meg McGrath who um is up
there I think she's next to that super
large pumpkin
um
uh okay so
um imagine you're the farmer I sent you
this um well actually what I did first
was I sent a recruitment letter to the
280 Farmers that identified to meet our
selection criteria uh and this letter
said we're going to do this survey we
really want you to participate if you
don't want to receive the survey let us
know uh one farmer called me and said I
don't want to be a part of your survey
uh take me off your list so ultimately
the surveys were sent to 279 Farmers
that met our selection criteria
um
after a short period of time we also
sent them a reminder postcard and this
postcard went to non-respondent so
people that I hadn't received soil
samples from yet received this first
reminder and then they also received
non-respondence received a second
reminder and I did a targeted telephone
solicitation to Farmers and counties
that I hadn't heard from yet uh uh try
to promote participation in the project
so the total sampling period for the
project was 77 days
um
so I want to talk a little bit about the
statistics now I've kind of talked about
the nuts and bolts of the survey process
so
um
to be able to understand how Farmers
vary in their beliefs it requires some
collapsing of the data that we collected
so
um or the data that we collected on
Farmers beliefs in the microbiome what
Farmers think are influencing the
microbiome within their farming system
um I conducted principal components
analysis that collapsed the
dimensionality of those questions down
to two Dimensions
um and then I conducted Affinity
propagation which is another clustering
approach so ultimately uh
develop clusters that represent the
beliefs of farmers so any farmer that
falls within a cluster ultimately held
similar beliefs in terms of the factor
that influence the microbiome on their
Farm
uh and then to verify that the
clustering solution was
um optimal I also evaluated uh I also
varied this thing called the preference
value which evaluates convergence and
and make sure that you're um that you're
clustering is the optimal solution
so um then I'll talk a little bit about
the regressions and model selections
that are ultimately going to tell us
what mediates
um production practices so as you might
um guess what I'm modeling here is
production practices as a response
variable so uh the production practices
we evaluated included irrigation cover
cropping fertilizer use crop diversity
tillage mulching pre-planting and
pesticide use and then I also included a
variable for motivations so as a
dependent variable which evaluates based
on the other factors the explanatory
variables how motivated was someone to
adopt a practice to help promote the
microbiome within their farming system
um I also wanted to mention that this
motivation data I wanted to look at
individual motivations and so I
conducted some Wilcox and ranked thumb
tests to evaluate how individual
variables motivate the farmers within
our survey
um and so then the explanatory variables
for the this modeling approach include
the belief clusters so uh what does
someone believe and how does that
influence what they do their production
practices uh farmer demographics like I
said variables like age generation
education and income and then Farm
characteristics very variables like area
certified area and organic production
and time and organic sorry the amount of
time the farm had been certified organic
um I also included a couple of extra
terms in this modeling approach or this
model selection approach uh to get at
um just some basic like data control
things so there's an effort variable and
then there was also null models that
were included in our in our modeling
approach
um finally I wanted to talk a little bit
about um The Intercept in these models
so for models that we're looking at the
clusters of farmer beliefs
um what you'll see in the coming slides
is that there's a cluster at the
um the center center of the principal
component analysis and that cluster is
serving as the intercept and models that
evaluate the response of production
practices or motivations uh to Farmers
beliefs and so all comparisons are from
that Central uh cluster of farmers
okay so I'm gonna go ahead and get into
some of the results here
um
the survey generated at 30.5 response
rate this was one farmer more than we uh
desired
um so at 30 which is good
um the uh the the target for us was
about about a 30 response rate and
usually surveys
um don't ever get to the desired
response rate so
um 30 is like the minimum threshold for
a response rate that you would want in a
survey but most the time you don't get
there so
um this shows that we had a lot of
Engagement from the organic farming
community
um so 85 Farmers responded to our survey
so 85 out of 279
um and then this is a map of where we
receive responses from uh red are
counties that didn't um respond to us
but had bombers that met our selection
criteria blew our counties that um did
not have any certified organic farms
meeting our selection criteria and then
any other color uh represents uh
counties that we received surveys from
and then the numerical counts uh from
each of those counties
so you can see uh Long Island had 11
surveys submitted we had really great
support from extension people on Long
Island in addition to Meg so big shout
out to Meg again for helping with
generating interest in the survey tool
but um you can also see that
participation was incredibly widespread
throughout the state
okay so um I want to talk about the
clustering of farmers by their beliefs
we determined that a seven cluster
solution was the optimal solution so
this was when I modified that preference
value so this just shows you that there
are a lot of unstable clustering
Solutions so these are unsupported
solution and then this long straight
segment are a series of seven cluster
solutions that was highly stable and
that and we selected that as our optimal
solution for the number of clusters that
we could that we could support in terms
of grouping Farmers by their beliefs of
the microbiome
so this is um this is the cluster
analysis
um reprojected into the principal
components face so what you can see are
the the seven clusters here each cluster
is represented by a color you can see
incredibly good separation of the
Clusters
um and then the six main clusters exist
kind of in this
um sorry I'm gesturing with my hand in
this space here and then we have the
seventh cluster down here in the bottom
left hand corner
um so I want to explain each of the axes
here so on this rotated component of one
uh these are factors that are external
to the farm so these are farmers that
either believe factors external to the
farm like climate change and pesticide
use and bordering lands influences the
microbiome within their farming system
or for example didn't believe that
and then on the x-axis here for rc3 we
have on-farm management so these are
farmers that believe things that they're
doing within their farming system either
influence the microbiome within their
Farm or don't influence the microbiome
within their Farm they're typically uh
what what you see is that farmers on the
negative components uh negative acts
negative part of each of the axes are
farmers that generally did not think
that either external factors or factors
internal to their Farm are influencing
their microbiome
and then this is the central cluster I
was talking uh talking about earlier
this is The Intercept in the models
um
does anyone want to guess what this
cluster what their response was
really common in survey tools
but it's similar to no answer but um
it's uh these are all the farmers that
said everything was somewhat important
for influencing the microbiome within
their farming system so this is just the
middle of the road people who are just
like all the way down the survey they
were like everything is just a little
bit of important this is really super
common in survey tools where people are
like I'm just not sure so I'm just going
to put somewhat important all the way
down
um so I'm not going to spend a whole lot
of time uh on on all of the results but
I just wanted to show you that from our
modeling approach we did find that what
Farmers believe does influence or is
correlated to the practices that they're
using and then um Farmers that for
example believe that their farming
practices influence the microbiome
ultimately use fewer practices that we
think could be detrimental to the
microbiome like pesticide use so I'm not
going to walk through all of these
results I don't have enough time but I
also wanted to show
that a lot of the farming practices were
also related to farm characteristics and
demographics so Farms are complex
socioecological systems not only their
beliefs that are regulating the
practices that they use so a few of the
factors that we found were important for
influencing practices that we think
could mediate the microbiome include the
farmer's age
um and their source of income as well as
their certified area in organic
production uh and time in organic
production so you can see that for
example a lot of these Trends are kind
of like downward facing so for example
one of the things that we think could be
related to microbiome diversity within
organic farming systems is crop
diversity and what we found is that um
as Farms have more certified acres in
organic production they actually reduce
their crop diversity so that might
ultimately tell us that some of these
larger Farms that are less Diversified
might have simpler microbiomes but we
don't know we can test that
um
and then finally I wanted to talk a
little bit about we've talked a little
bit about like what's influencing
Farmers current farming practices or
their adoption of practices so far but I
want to talk a little bit about what
might motivate a farmer
um to adopt a new practice to support
the microbiome so what we've found is
that farmers have tended to believe
either factor is external to the farm or
their farming practices are important
for mediating the microbiome within
their Farm we're more motivated to adopt
a new practice so farmers that are
already kind of interested and queued
into the factors that are mediating the
microbiome within their farming system
are also more motivated to adopt a new
practice and in addition to that
motivations were strongly driven by pest
reduction so when you asked Farmers when
we asked Farmers what might motivate you
to adopt a new practice and support the
microbiome within your farm pest
reductions uh where the top factor for
mediating uh their motivation
um so I'm just gonna kind of wrap this
up here by talking a little bit about
some of the key take-home messages
um this is some data that I didn't uh go
go through earlier but we also asked
Farmers
um do you believe that the microbiome
within your farm can enhance pest
suppression through mediating plant
defenses and they said yes they believe
um in what we're studying here so that's
really super important because we want
the farmers to at least be interested in
and believe in this process as as kind
of square one
um we did find that beliefs mediate
practices and farmer motivations
and that farming system characteristics
also mediate farming practices that
could influence the microbiome so you
don't always have to know what someone
believes to understand their farming
practices and ultimately some of these
data are widely collected by the USDA it
might be able to make some predictions
about farming practices that farmers are
using at Broad Geographic scales
um and then if we understand which
farming practices are related to
microbiome conservation and we might be
able to get sort of an idea or
prediction of um where uh where farming
practices are being used it might
support the microbiome
um or the opposite of that as well
um so this is kind of interesting uh
when we think about what Farmers believe
some Farmers didn't believe that their
farming practices influence the
microbiome within their Farm
um so when we're thinking about shaping
um and educating and doing Outreach it's
really under important to understand
where farmers are starting from in terms
of their knowledge and so we can start
addressing
um what Farmers think about the
microbiome
um and and extension efforts can be
geared towards addressing farmer beliefs
and their pedagogical approaches
and then the final key take-home message
was that proof of pest reductions is an
important part of motivating Farmers to
adopt a new practice to support the
microbiome but several of these factors
are also very highly ranked together
like ease of integration environmental
benefits like conservation and increased
yield so really any one of those if we
could prove any one of those that might
help motivate Farmers to adopt a
practice to support the microbiome
within their farming system
okay um I really sped through that
because I wanted to get to the the kind
of ecological component of this model
um and I'm tentatively titling this uh
this um paper eventual paper as farmer
believes indirectly mediate microbiome
diversity destabiling pest populations
in organic farming systems uh the
original paper that Claire uh wrote on
the subject went to Nature plants so I'm
thinking maybe this will go to Nature
plants is like the follow-up to Clara's
study
um I think we could maybe shoot for that
I don't know we'll see how it all how it
all turns out
um so as you'll as you'll recall uh the
the survey tool also included
instructions for how to uh submit a soil
sample so we asked Farmers to collect
some like very basic equipment from
their Farm like a bucket uh and a shovel
and a knife
um then we told them we wanted them to
go out to their field and evenly sample
the field avoiding any strange areas
um and then
basically we just asked them to you know
take a a soil sample core
um with their shovel so you can see we
asked them to kind of cut up head away
at this excess here uh and have like
about a six inch core
um and then we kind of had them
um mix uh all of the sub samples
together in that bin and so it's a bulk
soil sample from
um their field so it's important to note
that this soil sample came from the
field where they recorded their
production practices so this soil sample
is a representation of the ecological
outcomes that they recorded in their
survey tool
um so they sent us the survey tool back
and those also came with this oil sample
so we ended up with a with a bunch of
soil samples uh from these Farmers
um it was really cool if you ever want
to work with mail services on something
like that there's a lot of details
making this happen but as is a really
really neat
um so upon receiving the samples uh the
soil went into two different pipelines
uh the first pipeline was the bioassay
pipeline so the soil sample was stored
in a walk-in cooler and then I used
parts of that soil sample to run
bioassays and then another part of that
soil sample went into the sequencing
pipeline where I took the portion of the
soil sample and I stored it immediately
in a negative 20 freezer and then uh I
took soil out of that soil sample for
sequencing of the soil microbiome
um so I'll talk a little bit about the
sequencing pipeline I think um you know
for people in this department this
pipeline is incredibly familiar and it's
you know a capewalk for you but for me I
came to learn kind of about this kind of
stuff so that's part of the point of me
being here
um so the first thing was that I uh I
stored it in the negative 20 for this
Pipeline and for this kit it needs to be
super dry so I dried the soil in the BSC
uh
um and then I just ran it through a kind
of typical soil
um DNA extraction kit from apply gen I
use PCR to verify that
um
that the target regions Amplified and
then I sent the soil samp the DNA
samples out for each of the soil samples
for sequencing of the V4 V5 and its
region at Dalhousie University so I
didn't do the sequencing or Library prep
or any of that stuff in-house and then
um the results came back and I ran the
files through the data 2 Pipeline and I
assigned taxonomy using the Silva and
unite Community databases I'm really not
going to talk at all about taxonomy
assignment today and everything that I'm
going to show you today is at the level
of the ASV
so that kind of gives you an indication
at the resolution that I'm working with
here
um so once you have this community data
you need to kind of develop some
measures for it and so one of the
thoughts is that I would use Hill
numbers to quantify different aspects of
diversity or biodiversity within each of
the soil samples and so I've done this
but today I'm only going to focus on the
Shannon index and the Shannon index is
an index that accounts for the relative
abundance of each of the asvs and then
some of these other measures like
richness is just a count of each ASB for
example and Simpsons index accounts for
unevenness within the community Matrix
but I'm just going to talk about Shannon
index which is um include the relative
abundance of each of the asvs
so that's um that's the sequencing
pipeline I'm going to talk a little bit
about the bioassay pipeline now so these
are the soil samples that went into the
walk-in freezer
um one thing that I haven't explained to
you yet is that within this clustering
approach uh one of the values of using
Affinity propagation is that it
identifies exemplars so each of these
square boxes are real world Farms that
represent the beliefs of all the other
Farms within that cluster so rather than
using all 85 Farms to evaluate the
ecological outcome of the soil sample on
pest suppression I'm able to just use
the seven exemplars represented by these
points in those bile assays which you
can imagine greatly reduced the amount
of replications and things like that
that I needed to do
so the Exemplar soil samples
um uh we use an extraction method that's
very rudimentary it's a whole bulk soil
sample we take some of that soil we put
it into a nutrient solution and we shake
it together and then we try to get as
much of the soil out so what's left in
the nutrient solution is just what we
think is a representation of the the
microbiome within that soil sample so
then I took uh that soil that solution
that nutrient solution and I applied it
to pea plants I put aphids on those pea
plants and then I counted the progeny of
those aphids after nine days and then I
also took Leaf tissue samples too to
quantify plant defenses
so this is another representation of my
bioassays I'm just showing this to kind
of give you an idea that half of the
plants received aphids and half of them
did not receive aphids and so this other
half here will allow us to evaluate
eventually priming via the microbiome
um and then the other half of this will
be able to kind of look more like
induction or recruitment so what happens
when you apply an aphid and is the plan
able to recruit the microbiome to defend
itself after the aphid has been applied
so uh some additional controlling
covariates here so um we know that for
example farming practices might mediate
the microbiome but uh soil properties
are incredibly important so I use the
USGS web soil survey and each one of our
Farms
um I extracted data on uh pH organic
matter percent sand silt and Clay
available water content in this variable
called the erosion factor and so all
this data is also pulled down to help
control for how soil properties could be
influencing the microbiome and not other
things like farming practices that we're
interested in so how do you control for
those variables that's what we're doing
here this web soil survey is is great uh
the resolution the spatial resolution is
incredibly fine and if you're good at
GIS
um
it's a it's a great resource
okay so um you might be asking yourself
how are you going to model all this
information together
um and so what Claire and our
collaborator ultimately decided on was
using um a structural equation modeling
approach
um and so best practice is defining what
your meta model is and so this is a meta
model of how we think um how we theorize
the system works so the basic idea is
that belief speediate farming practices
those farming practices mediate
microbiome diversity microbiome
diversity ultimately mediates plant
defenses plant defenses ultimately
mediate pest depression this is how we
think the model works but we also want
to control for other things like farming
system characteristics like time and
organic management which I hypothesize
could have a direct effect on microbiome
diversity or could influence farming
practices which then indirectly sorry so
um time and organic management would
ultimately indirectly impact microbiome
diversity
demographics we don't think does have a
direct impact on the microbiome but
again that would be mediated through
farming practices and then those abiotic
factors the soil properties we think
those could have a direct influence on
the microbiome but also an indirectly
influence through farming practices
um so I'm gonna uh show you some kind of
complicated models in a in a second but
I wanted to just let you know that
um just like any modeling approach you
can over parameterize the model and then
you get really bad estimates
um and so for this modeling approach
that I'm going to tell you about I kind
of use it used my inference to select
some of the variables that I thought
might be important
um either the science or to Farmers so
for my abiotic factor I picked organic
matter because the farmer has said in
their survey that they thought organic
matter was an important factor for
influencing the microbiome within their
farming system so I wanted to test that
um in terms of farming practices you saw
from my survey that there's a lot of
different farming practices that I
evaluated but not all of them are
farming practices that if you told a
farmer to adopt they might be like hey
I'm going to do that tomorrow so I
decided to focus on two farming
practices uh one is no tillage which is
uh increase seeingly adopted within
organic vegetable production but it's
still on the adoption curve not everyone
is doing it and then pre-planting
practices like solarization and harping
which is also gaining Traction in New
York state
um so also included in the model were
the Clusters so their beliefs
um I for my demographical variable I
picked income which we found was an
important variable for influencing the
adoption of farming practices and then
for Farm characteristics like I said
before I picked time and organic
management and also thinking back on
this I might have included a couple of
other farming practices in here like the
application of compost was one
um
and the use of legume cover crops so all
these are practices that I think Farmers
might reasonably adopt if you said hey
this is going to really help microbiome
and pest depression within your farm how
am I doing it on time almost out of time
um
there's some Theory I'm going to skip
over this and I'll just show you the
model
so what I found in this model is beliefs
do influence
um indirectly influence the bacterium or
bacterial diversity in this influence
was caused through no tillage so we
don't believe that beliefs influence the
bacterium directly but what we found is
that as Farmers tended to believe more
that um their practices or external
factors influence the microbiome within
their Farm those Farmers tended to adopt
no tillage or use no tillage and as
Farmers adopted no-tilla just increased
bacterial biodiversity within their soil
sample
and then this is the model with um my uh
bioassay data in it so the previous one
was just the sequencing data and what I
found here is that
there's indirect links between beliefs
and variation in the afib population and
so what I ultimately determine is that
um
beliefs indirectly influence pest
outbreaks or variation in the afib
population through no tillage and
bacterial biodiversity
um so so key take-home points here
Farmers uh beliefs they tend to promote
practices that enhance the microbiome
and perhaps stabilize pest populations
so reduce the variation
um in their uh reduce the variation in
the population and keep it from reaching
outbreak levels
and these outcomes were mediated by no
tillage and the bacterium
and that um just a final take-home
message here is that stable pest
populations may be less inclined to
outbreaks and easier to suppress for
farmers
so um I still have to include the uh
plant defense data in this model so it's
not a finished model yet
and then the final step in this project
is to create what's called a dynamic
socioecological agent-based model we're
going to extend this information back to
Farmers and see if they're interested in
adopting any of these practices to help
promote the microbiome and pest
depression within their Farm
so that's it uh if thank you for your
time any questions or comments and if
you do um if you do social media you can
find me on Twitter at sustainability
and that's it
um so I have a question in the chat the
chat question is
um which pre-planting practices uh
reduced fungal diversity so
um yeah so this is a really interesting
outcome here
um we're talking about oops let me not
go back
okay
um we're talking about this pathway here
and so um we're talking about
solarization
um and um
tarping here those were grouped together
into one pre-planting packet practice
variable and we were really interested
in this pathway too and what we think is
going on is that uh pre-planting
practices like solarization and tarping
are reducing fungal diversity but it's
possible that those reductions in fungal
diversity
um could be the reduction of pathogenic
species and we just haven't done the
follow-up analysis to understand this
um because if you look at this
um the addition here you we do see that
the remaining fungal diversity also has
this influence on the aphid populations
but we also have done a little bit of
analysis that does the modeling on a
species by species level and some of the
top species that are lost due to
pre-planting practices are potentially
plant pathogens and that's one of the
reasons that you would want to use those
practices so there's definitely a lot of
follow-up analyzes that we want to do
with these data
um I think we're out of time
so join me again thank you Eli
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu